[Musique]
louis les 20 qu'a acheté il ya un an
l'usiné de transformation cowie à granby
dont le but d'élargir l'offre dans le
marché du poisson le consommateur à fait
content qui veut y ait besoin de manger
de plus en plus rapidement ses sols et
vit aujourd'hui les familles sont
occupés les enfants de l'école qui
veulent de quoi rapide
il existe beaucoup de choses mais des
choses santé à base de poisson c'est
très rare nous ce qu'on a essayé de
faire c'est de faire un rapport complet
et dompter les légumes poissons de la
sauce jeunesse mettre au fond
[Musique]
dans les congélateurs des épiceries aux
côtés des filets de poisson on retrouve
désormais un vaste choix de filet prix
assaisonner il ne reste plus qu'à les
faire cuire lui on mettait congelés donc
c'est parfait
nicolas gagnon enseignante ali thq et
deux étudiants vont tester pour nous un
échantillonnage de sept produits parmi
tous les filets surgelés offert notre
choix s'est arrêté sur le saumon un
poisson très populaire premières
impressions sur ce que vous avez observé
on a beaucoup aimé ce dont on observer
que le morceau de poisson ressembler à
ce qu'on trouve en épicerie c'est
toujours à sur un tout petit peu
évidemment nous regarde un peu la liste
des ingrédients
on a un préjugé favorable avec ceux qui
ont des ingrédients qu'on peut retrouver
chez nous nous avons choisi la cuisson
au four afin d'uniformiser l'expérience
seul le sans fausse note est cuit sous
vide dans l'eau chaude côté saisi vers
le haut
pour les autres produits cuisson au four
généralement 400 degrés fahrenheit
les instructions sont toutes très clair
c'est hyper assaisonner de son côté la
nutritionniste catherine lefebvre s'est
penché sur les valeurs nutritives des
différents filet si on regarde au niveau
de la qualité des produits au point de
vue nutritionnel c'est pas toujours les
meilleures options parce que comme dans
tous les produits qui sont assaisonnés à
l'avance il peut se il peut y avoir des
ingrédients le poste pas tout à fait
intéressante ça peut venir jouer au
niveau du sodium évidemment même
d'additifs alimentaires dont on ne peut
vraiment besoin premier constat les
assaisonnements masque souvent le goût
du poisson
c'est le cas du saumon poids les sélects
de high liner que ça votre leçon non
personnellement le saumon moi je trouve
que ça commence les herbes quel moment
exactement le blue water de son côté a
étonné par sa forme rectangulaire
mais son goût laisse indifférent ouais
en fait la sauce
elle a l'air bonne et la leyre bella
l'héroïne seulement exactement mais bon
on aime ou on n'aime pas ses traits
chimiques dont le sait très chimiques ou
moins comme vous pour ce qui est des
portions marine et de high liner
encore une fois le goût est masquée par
les assaisonnements j'ai entendu ton
speer ouais vous fac est vraiment debout
de son nom le goût de saumon n'est pas
ce qui c'est sec et c'était au tout en
fait on goûte le sel le taux de sodium
very beaucoup dans notre échantillonnage
de 240 mg pour une portion de 89 g à
1530 mg pour cette grosse portion de 275
gras le sucre s'est également frayer un
chemin dans ces produits
étonnamment on retrouve quand même du
sucre dans des poissons assaisonner dans
les produits analysés on a des poissons
qui vont avoir jusqu'à 6 cuillères à thé
de sucre par phil et d'options cuisine à
la maison est ce qu'on voit mettre
l'équivalent de 6 cuillerées à thé de
sucre son autre fils et un seul
évidemment que non
le cidb qu'il acquit à l'érable contient
pas moins de 30 g de sucre mais il a la
liste d'ingrédients la plus courte du
groupe
il a plu au panel de testeurs il ya six
ingrédients on les connaît tous au
niveau du goût aussi satisfaisant parce
que on s'attend à ça mon côté il ya la
peau pour moi trop ça rassurant
parmi les saumons tester quelques
mentions honorables le sans fausse note
cuit sous vide on sent bien la coriandre
c'est sucré mais avec terry a qui ont si
apam et en ce sens on goûte bien la
ligne 1 coriance et c'est agréable
puis on sent que c'est floconneux
lock-out quand on est constamment
il ya quand même beaucoup de sauts cela
faisait moins présent ouais non ça peu
plus son nom disparaît effectivement
puis le filet au feu de high line ce que
j'aime c'est qu'on goûte le son nom avec
juste un peu de fumée on est le petit
côté sucré
quand on fait on l'attendait bien là
dessus c'est vraiment la texture ce soit
je le trouve un peu siècle mais c'est
sûr qu'il ya des morceaux qui sont un
peu plus épais aussi dans l'emballage
fait que peut-être que celui là serait
atteignant maintenant leurs pas sur mon
et légumes de kogi ya plein de bonnes
idées là dedans il ya plein de choses
hyper pratique
je pense qu'on a voulu mettre un paquet
de légumes bio les légumineuses ce juste
heureux travailler un petit peu les
épices sabre est intéressant parce qu'au
niveau texture on avait bien apprécié un
vendu entre 6 et 15 dollars la plupart
des saumons sont trop assaisonner selon
nos boutard et surtout trop cuit si on
suit à la lettre les recommandations des
fabricants parmi les produits lundi je
trouve pas que vraiment un excellent
rapport qualité prix
le poisson s'est su partager la poire à
la maison c'est super facile à
aromatiser je pense qu'on est vraiment
gagnant de le cuisiner nouman
[Musique]